This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Ranini. My mind was blown.
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves.
We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. This is a topic that has been a long time coming, but I've been kind of like holding off on doing it until I had some actual lived experience on the matter.
and now that I can definitely say that I do, I want to talk about what it's like living with your partner in your 20s and whether or not you should do it. So I have been with my partner Tom now for three years. I feel like you guys have been here for the entire life cycle of our relationship from like when I was on my dating detox to when I met him afterwards. And what you may or may not know is that we did kind of like, we had like a medium distance relationship for some time where I live in Sydney. He lives in Wollongong.
It's kind of like an hour and a half, two hour drive. Not really long distance. Not particularly like easy to pop over and see each other. And about a year in, he basically decided like, okay, I'm going to move to Sydney so that we can be closer. We had this huge discussion of do we move in with each other? Do we move in with each other after really only being together for like a year? And we decided not to.
and I will say this, that was one of the best decisions that we made for our relationship. I honestly think it is like one of the reasons we are so solid today because we didn't put out, put the pedal to the metal in our relationship and we really took our time to kind of go through all the milestones of being in a relationship and being with somebody. And six months ago, we finally decided like, okay, no, now is the time. We've been together for like two and a half years. Let's move in together. And we kind of did it on our own terms.
And there was a lot of times when we were like, this would be really convenient. We basically already see each other every day anyways. And we didn't do it. And I think that how we went about it has really taught me a lot and how we now live together has taught me a lot about the pros and cons of living with your partner in your 20s. I will say it is amazing. It is objectively so much. fun and like just has made my life so much better but there are definitely things to think about
when you make this decision like you are basically guaranteeing that either you end up together long term you end up married or any breakup is going to be like 20 times more painful and there is definitely an urge when you were in the early stages of a relationship to want to build the life together without actually really knowing who you're dating yet whilst you're still kind of in the honeymoon period and i'd really warn against that and i'm going to explain exactly why why it's sometimes really really important to wait what you need to know about your partner before you sign a lease together before they move into your house and some of like the biggest hurdles that you will unfortunately and uncomfortably come across when you live with the person that you love more than anything else
in the world. So I'm very excited to get into this to, of course, break down the psychology of this dynamic to give you some, I guess, unsolicited advice, but you're listening to this episode. So it's solicited, I'm assuming. Without further ado, let's get into should you live with your partner in your 20s? This question of should I move in with my partner in my 20s seems pretty simple. At first, you know, you already kind of spend every night at each other's places. You've got a toothbrush in their bathroom. Your wardrobe is in their closet. You love each other.
You get along. Why not just take the next step? There is something, though, about living with your partner, rather than just spending time in your living environments with your partner, that will change the whole dynamic of your relationship, whether you want it to or not, and whether for better or for worse. Now, traditionally, there have been, I think, two big schools of thought about do you live with somebody in your 20s? Or do you live with somebody before marriage?
And the first thought is that moving in before marriage, before a ring, can somehow ruin the magic, right? Cohabiding, it should be left for like the sanctity of marriage. This is a particularly religious or conservative idea, of course. It's definitely actually become more popular in modern day as well with people recognizing the benefit of living apart for longer, maintaining financial independence, maintaining personal independence, even just like being able to have separate lives is actually quite healthy for relationships that are still quite young or occurring when you are quite young. The second school of thought is that you should live with somebody before you get married,
you should live with somebody in your 20s before you really take things to the next serious level. The argument is, you know, how else are you going to know? How else are you going to know that you're actually compatible in the day to day? Living with each other is like a trial run, right, for the rest of your life. It's like a way to test the waters before you sign like the metaphorical lease of forever. Now, marriage is also not the end goal for everybody anymore. Some people never want to get married or it's not something that they're rushing to do. So, I do think we shouldn't be thinking of this big conundrum. Do I live with my partner in my 20s or not? We shouldn't be thinking about it in terms of marriage, but in terms of what do we stand to gain
and what might I risk by living with somebody in this formative period of my life based on my values, based on my future plans, whether that's marriage or not, based on my current lifestyle. What do I gain? What might I lose? Let's start with what you can gain. What are some of the pros of living with somebody in your 20s. The biggest pro is honestly that it's so much fun. Like you can't put a number on how enjoyable it is if you've moved in with the right person to just like go to bed every night and just laugh and giggle and it's just marvelous.
Everything that's like mundane normally, grocery shopping, your commute, cooking dinner becomes like so much more fun. It just is genuinely a dream. I think financially, And logistically, it can also make a lot of sense, right? The cost of living, especially in our 20s, when you might still be figuring out your career, you're paying off student loans, let's just not kid ourselves, the global economic climate is not amazing. It can be really brutal.
I live in Sydney. I live in the second most expensive city in the world. I have heard from friends in London and New York also very expensive cities that finances are a major factor in determining when people move in with their partners. In fact, people move in a lot quicker just to get that like economic and financial relief. You know, rent is rising, groceries, cost a small fortune. Moving in together is a practical solution. I saw this 2023 survey online done in the US that found that 54%. So just over half of cohabitating couples say that finances are a major reason they move in together. Honestly, it's not a bad reason as long as it is not the only reason.
Now, there is this very famous study about sliding versus deciding in a relationship that I think really convinces me that money cannot be the only reason you choose to live with somebody. This paper basically says, this theory basically says that when couples make major relationship transitions, they do one of two things. They either slide, meaning they gradually and often unconsciously increase commitment without explicit discussion or intention. So they move in together just because it is right and convenient and because it just seems like the basic next step, versus they decide, meaning they make a clear, mutual, deliberate choice to deepen commitment. They have conversations about it.
Yes, they're still considering practical factors that may slide the decision, but they're in a rational, deliberate mind about the choice. So the authors of this study found that those who slide into big transitions often end up a lot less happy and they are much more likely to break up, largely because they never clarified expectations. They never were really aligned beforehand. And they never may have discussed important things that you need to know about somebody before you live with them.
They just saw it as the easy, available next step. And that ambiguity, it can lead to asymmetric commitment. You know, because the biggest factor is convenience, you don't really know how in somebody is because of their actual love for you and how in they are because of practicality. Yes, living with your partner can help you save money, but living with somebody out of financial necessity rather than emotional readiness adds a lot of pressure to a relationship very, very quickly.
So that's just something to consider. But finances, still a pro. The third pro, the third thing you stand to gain is that it's incredibly convenient. You save, I cannot begin. The amount of time that me and Tom save, not having to commute to each other's houses between, you know, basically two different major cities every weekend or every day is incredible. And I think especially for him, when we were doing that kind of like medium distance relationship, he, you know, it may have looked like
he was living in Wollongong. It may have looked like he was living at my house. He was living out of his car. Like, let's be completely real real about it. Like he had everything he needed. Like he could have moved into his car because all of his stuff was in there because of this back and forth. I think it's not just that it's physically convenient. It will also bring you together emotionally. And I consider this a pro. I think it really tests the strength of your emotional bond. You know, it is one thing to love somebody when they are all dressed up and you're out for dinner and everybody's on their best behavior.
It's another thing to love them when they're really stressed, really tired, really grumpy because somebody left. the dishes in the sink, really hangary, all those different things. I think cohabitation gives you a front row seat to who your partner really is. Again, that's a pro for me. Ideally, you should have seen some of these things before you made the decision. Sometimes you don't. I personally, I really think that you shouldn't move in with somebody during your honeymoon period. That's just my kind of, that's just my opinion. Because in that first like 12 to 18 months of a relationship when you were just like madly in love, there is nothing wrong with this person. You cannot see past the bad stuff to the more messy things. And I think that when you move in with somebody during that phase,
it makes it so much harder to really like adjust when those things eventually come out. So I think, yes, living with somebody gives you a front row seat to those things. You also hopefully should have seen it before. You know, back to that previous point, that's why people call living together, like the relationship accelerator. Everything is sped up, the connection, but also the conflict, the communication, the hobbies you share, the relationship you have. You can learn in six months of living with somebody,
but it may have taken two to three years to learn about them. So you just need to know you're ready for that kind of shock of either, you know, loving somebody even deeper. because of that or being a little bit scared off. I will say, you're probably like, why is this on the pros list? I think it's on the pros list because, you know, this is going to sound cynical, but eventually you're going to learn about these things, right? And living together means you learn about them quicker.
And if they are really big deal breakers, like, it does save you a lot of time. And I think that, think of that as a pro. And then, you know, if it does work out and you determine that you are really compatible, well then you just get to know somebody even more intimately. So either way, like, I do think that you know somebody better and whether you know that they're not right for you or know that they are right for you, that is still a huge, huge win. I think a big reason why it is so emotionally intimate as well, just to like further hone in on this point is because this is the first person since your family to see you at this level of like,
intimate proximity. When you live alone, when you live with friends, there's still a degree of performance, even if it's small. You do still try to be more tidy and try to be a more functional adult version of yourself. But living with your partner, I think removes that layer. Like they do truly see everything in a lot of ways. Cohabitation feels very familiar. This is what I found. I feel like it's the first time I've done it, but it just feels like I've done it before because it mirrors that deep domestic intimacy that you have with your family, the sharing of space, the sharing of chores, the sharing of life, of the background noise of day to day. This time though, I think it's like a beautiful thing that you are, you're getting to choose your family.
You're choosing the person you want to move in with. You're choosing your partner rather than just being in the family. that you're born into. It will though, somebody, something that I don't see people talk about a lot is when you move in with somebody, you will experience this thing called family reenactment. Basically, all of us carry emotional patterns that we've learned from early on from across our lives, emotional patterns to do with affection, to do with conflict, responsibility, communication. And when you are with your partner and there is that same level of intimacy as you had with your family, this stuff is going to come out.
And it might shock you. It might honestly terrify you to be like, wait, I'm in this big adult relationship and suddenly I'm acting like a child again. Why does that happen? Because I know that's a pretty common experience where you kind of feel like you're reversing in maturity. Well, we're going to talk about all of that as well as some other complexities of living with somebody after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take.
the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim?
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you're just so you're not. y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast. Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your Facebook. favorite therapist, Kear Games.
And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends,
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed.
I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So you're moving with your partner. you're feeling super grown up and then you find yourself regressing. Why is that?
There's a really key psychoanalytic theory you should know called object relations theory that explains this really well. The theory was developed in psychoanalytic psychology by Melanie Klein and Donald Winnicott and they basically suggest that our earliest relationships, i.e., those with our parents or caregivers become internalized as objects. And by that, I don't mean physical objects, but emotional templates. These internal objects or templates represent how we learned to relate to love, relate to care, safety, and dependence.
For example, if your primary caregiver was warm and reliable, your internal template or object is one that tells you that intimacy feels safe, that love can be trusted. But if your caregiver was inconsistent, was critical, love was conditional, you carry around an internal template that says love is unstable, love has to be earned. Fast forward to your 20s and suddenly, you know, you're living with your partner, the person who was closest to you since those original caregivers, those internalized dynamics will reappear.
This is where this concept of transference comes in. this is the process whereby we project old feelings and expectations from our early relationships onto our current ones, especially during times when things feel a bit unstable or new, like when you move in with somebody. It's fun. It's also stressful. Transference makes cohabitation so emotionally rich because you're sharing internal worlds, you're sharing emotional histories.
you, there's just the nature of the environment and the closeness that you are having is going to feel reminiscent of previous times you felt this close to people. And those reactive or reactionary patterns will often be the same. Now, the thing is, this is not always a bad thing. Sometimes it's actually an opportunity to rewrite previous models, previous templates of how you relate to people. you know, unlike your family dynamic, this relationship is chosen. You're not a kid anymore. You have self-awareness. You have hopefully a quality.
You can communicate and you can actually address issues that come up in a way that your childhood self couldn't and say, hey, you know, when you get quiet during arguments, it reminds me of how silence felt in my house. I don't want to do that anymore. Can we talk about this differently? I need you to be or to make more time for me because otherwise I, feel my abandonment wound really firing up. And that's how transference really can turn into deep emotional transformation. If you are with the right person and you're living together,
you get to rewrite the emotional scripts you are handed. You create new templates for what love and safety and care can feel like. And I count that as a huge pro. I think a lot of my cons are also pros, right? When else do you have the opportunity? And it's, it truly is an opportunity to rewire your primal childhood wounds. So just to give it a little rundown, pros, convenience, it makes financial sense. Now the pro of living together is it's just a lot of fun. It also challenges your emotional bond and it really tells you whether you should or shouldn't be with somebody.
You know, obviously that might end in a breakup. that's not necessarily a bad thing if it saves you a lot of time. So with that in mind, let's switch gears. Let's talk about the harder parts, the things you should definitely be aware of before choosing to live with somebody in your 20s. Now, one of the biggest drawbacks, and it's going to be ironic that I mentioned this, considering what I just said, is that any future breakup is going to be a lot more complicated. Not that it wasn't, isn't going to be right, it's just going to be complicated.
and no matter how in love you are, how strong the first few months of living together are, how strong you guys are as a couple before you move in, you are going to have moments where you fight and you argue and you feel like, you know, what are we doing? Like, can we work through this? It's just totally normal for couples to go through that. And maybe the answer you come to is no. when you live separately and you break up, you don't have kids, you don't have shared furniture, you don't have a pet, you can just leave. You cry, you unfollow, you heal, your space is not
their space. When you live together, there's a lease, there's shared furniture, there's the shared pet, there's a shared life, there's shared bank accounts maybe. These logistics alone can turn an emotionally hard breakup into a logistical nightmare. This has happened to, a few friends of mine. And it was honestly really hard to see them go through it. I know it was for the best, but, you know, at times, like one of my friends had to continue living in an apartment with somebody who cheated on her. And the guy was in a new relationship because they had this lease and she couldn't afford to break it. Like, that is tough. Or the alternative is you ignore red flags to avoid the complications of a breakup because mentally now that you live together, you think it's going to be
way too difficult. There is a term for this in psychology. It's called relationship inertia. It describes how living together can actually make people stay in relationships longer than they would have otherwise simply because it's harder to leave. The thought of moving out, the thought of dividing belongings, of finding a new place. It can all make staying just seem a lot, easier, even if you're unhappy. And then where does that leave you? In a relationship you don't want to be in, all because you made a decision maybe a little bit too early.
We're going to return to the role of finances here as well. It comes up, yet again, I feel like money is both the biggest pro and the biggest con. Sharing rent and bills seems like it's going to be straightforward. It's going to save you money. It does actually introduce a layer of dependency that can be really tricky to navigate. what happens if one of you loses a job? What if you earn significantly different amounts? Do you split everything 50-50 or do you split it proportionally?
What if you buy a property? You know, that's a whole other legal layer. Money, as we know from research conducted in 2014, is the biggest source of relationship conflict and cohabitation brings that right to the surface. It's also, as that previous study said, one of the biggest reasons people move in together. I actually saw a recent vice article aptly titled Till Debt Do Us Part, which talked about this.
如果你买房呢？你知道，那涉及完全不同的法律层面。正如我们从2014年的一项研究所知，金钱是伴侣冲突的最大导火索，而同居会把这个问题彻底暴露出来。正如之前那项研究所说，这也是人们决定搬到一起住的最大原因之一。我最近其实看到了一篇vice的文章，题目非常贴切，叫《直到债务将我们分离》，里面就讨论了这一点。
And one of the surveys they discussed found that nearly one in four Americans in a relationship would leave if they knew they could get out without going broke. That is a quarter of the people they spoke to. A quarter of people were like, I actually don't want to be in this relationship. Money is what's keeping me here. And this is what the financial state of so many countries is encouraging. It's economic codependence that means people are staying in relationships way longer than they should. And of course, that doesn't mean living together dooms you to inertia
他们讨论的一项调查发现，近四分之一身处恋爱中的美国人表示，如果知道自己分手后不会破产，他们就会选择离开。这可是他们访谈对象中四分之一的人。四分之一的人表示：我其实根本不想维持这段关系。是金钱让我留在这里。而这正是许多国家的经济现状所鼓励的。这种经济上的相互依赖意味着，人们维持恋爱关系的时间远比他们应该维持的要长得多。当然，这并不是说同居一定会让你陷入惯性，
or dooms you to financial codependency. You just have to be extra aware of your motivations. And I do also think that it's wise to still have your own bank account, to still have some of your own money. You know, you might trust this person with your life. People still make stupid mistakes. Things do still happen. It's not about having one foot out the door. It's just about being prepared for what life throws at you in the most rational and best possible way. Another practical con of moving in together is you do lose a lot of personal space and you just got to assess whether that's something you're willing to lose. You know, if you've ever lived alone, it's the best. I love living alone. You get to walk around in silence. You get to make as much or as little
或者注定让你陷入经济上的相互依赖。你只是需要对自己的动机有格外的觉察。而且我也认为，保留自己的银行账户、拥有一些属于自己的钱依然是明智的做法。你知道的，你可能把生命都托付给这个人。但人们还是会犯愚蠢的错误。意外依然会发生。这并不是说你随时留着一手，而是以最理性、最好的方式为生活可能带给你的挑战做好准备。同居的另一个现实劣势是，你确实会失去很多个人空间，你必须评估自己是否愿意失去这些空间。你知道，如果你曾经独居过，那感觉简直太棒了。我太喜欢独居了。你可以安安静静地走动。你可以制造任意多或任意少的
of a mess as possible. Your room and your house always gets to feel the way you want it to feel. You're in charge of the furniture. You're in charge of what's on the TV. When you live with somebody else, that solitude and the freedom of that solitude does drastically shrink. You know, suddenly your downtime is shared time. Your home, the place that you used to retreat to, does become a shared environment. And yes, in an ideal world, you choose to be in a relationship where you can be your wacky, wonderful, weird self in front of them comfortably, but regardless of that, you still do need personal time to function. One estimate I found suggests that the perfect ratio for a relationship is 70% of time together, 30% of time alone. That's the maximum level that people can
垃圾。你的房间和房子总是能保持你希望的样子。你做主家具的摆放。你做主电视上看什么。当你和另一个人一起生活时，那种独处以及独处带来的自由会急剧缩减。你知道的，突然之间，你的闲暇时间成了共享时间。你的家，那个你曾经的避风港，变成了一个共享的环境。是的，在理想世界里，你选择了一段这样的关系：你可以在对方面前舒舒服服地做那个古怪、精彩、奇奇怪怪的自己，但不管怎样，为了正常生活，你仍然需要个人时间。我发现的一个估算表明，一段关系的最佳比例是70%的相处时间，30%的独处时间。这是人们能够
can handle. So what I mean by is like if it went any higher than that, that's when a relationship does deeply suffer or does become hyperdependent. You just need to be able to recognize yourself as an individual. That's really what it means to be functioning in this relationship and out of it, having enough time to know who you are outside of the bounds of who this person is to you. I think what works for me and Tom is that I work from home all day. So I spend a lot of time by myself, whilst he is obviously at work and he has co-workers. And then when he gets home, I'll be out and we kind of switch shifts where he has his alone time. And that works really well for us that, you know, our evenings and our days on the week are kind of a little bit separate. Like,
承受的极限水平。我的意思是，如果比例再高一些，这段关系就会遭受严重损害，或者变得过度依赖。你只需要能够将自己识别为一个独立的个体。这才是维系这段关系、并在关系之外正常运作的真正含义：有足够的时间去了解，在对方对你的定义之外，你自己究竟是谁。对我跟汤姆很管用的是，我整天都在家工作。所以我花很多时间独处，而他显然去上班了，他有同事。然后等他回家时，我就出门，我们有点像在交接班，他有他的独处时间。这对我俩非常有效，你知道的，我们的夜晚和工作日有一点点是分开的。比如说，
obviously we still see each other when one of us gets home and we still go to the gym together and all that stuff. But then on weekends is when we have our quality time, right? We always take Talu our dog on like a big adventure. You know, it's her weekend too. And then we like do a big grocery shop. We go for a big run. We do a date night. It's the best. That works for us because I need a lot more alone time than he does. My work situation, his work situation allows that. He's in the office full time. I'm at home full time. But it's all about just managing expectations and making sure that they're aligned. With that in mind, let's talk about expectations for a second here. living together will raise your expectations for your partner.
当然，我们其中一人回家时我们还是会见到彼此，我们仍然会一起去健身房之类的。但到了周末，就是我们享受高质量相处时光的时候了，对吧？我们总是带我们的狗塔卢去进行一次大冒险。你知道的，这也是它的周末。然后我们会去进行大采购。我们会去跑个步。我们会安排约会之夜。这太棒了。这种模式对我们很管用，因为我比他需要更多的独处时间。我的工作状况和他的工作状况允许这种模式。他全职在办公室。我全职在家。但这全在于管理期望，并确保彼此的期望是一致的。带着这一点，我们来谈谈关于期望的问题。同居会提高你对伴侣的期望。
This person is no longer your weekend fund. This is your partner as in like needs to be by your side, should be by your side, has to support you through good and bad. Your expectations for them obviously increase. And when those expectations aren't met, resentment will grow in their place. Resentment as we know from relationship institutes, relationship researchers like the Gottman Institute is like a huge poison for a relationship. If you resent the other person without communicating it,
这个人不再只是陪你过周末的伴侣了。这是你的伴侣，意味着需要陪在你身边，应该陪在你身边，必须在顺境和逆境中支持你。你对他们的期望自然会提高。当这些期望没有得到满足时，怨恨就会滋生。正如我们从情感机构和戈特曼研究所等情感研究人员那里了解到的，怨恨是关系的巨大毒药。如果你对对方心怀怨恨却不沟通，
your relationship isn't going to last. And the first few months are usually the hardest when you are adjusting to each other's rhythms, you are adjusting to each other's routines and emotional lives. Conflict is going to increase in this time. I'm just going to let you know that. before you move in together, before you sign the lease, like you are going to fight probably the most in your relationship than you ever have in the first like six months that you live together.
你们的关系是不会长久的。通常头几个月是最艰难的，因为你们要适应彼此的节奏，适应彼此的日常规律和情感生活。这段时间的冲突将会增加。我提前告诉你。在你们同居之前，在你们签租房合同之前，在你们同居的前六个月里，你们吵架的频率可能是整段关系中最多的。
It's not a bad thing. It's a good thing. It's an adjustment thing. Just make sure you get to a solid ground with each other around what your expectations are now and what you maybe do and don't need from the relationship or from the future of your relationship. to remain happy in this like new chapter that you're sharing. So with all that in mind, I want to talk about the five things you need to be super clear on
这并不是一件坏事。这是一件好事，是一个适应的过程。只要确保你们能就当前的期望，以及你们可能需要或不需要从关系中或未来关系中得到什么，达成一个坚实的共识，以便在这个你们共同分享的新篇章中保持快乐。考虑到所有这些，我想谈谈在你20年代，
before living with somebody in your 20s. The first one is money. So number one, you need to understand finances. And I have five things that you need to agree on or sit down with each other and talk about before you sign the lease. How is rank going to be split? I literally want you to get a piece of pen and paper and write this down like you are writing down a contract. How is rent going to be split? Are you going to have shared accounts? Who is
在与人同居之前你需要非常明确的五件事。第一件事是金钱。所以第一点，你需要了解财务状况。在我签租赁合同之前，我有五件事你需要和对方达成一致或坐下来好好谈谈。房租将如何分摊？我真的希望你拿出一支笔和一张纸把它写下来，就像在写合同一样。房租将如何分摊？你们会有共享账户吗？谁来
responsible for managing and paying bills and when and which and does that change? What will you buy together and what will you buy separately? So like groceries, maybe one of you has really expensive hair care products. Maybe one of you wants to, has a car that the other person uses. Like, what are you going to pay for separately and together? What is your plan if one of you loses your income or loses your job. These are pretty dry questions. Super dry, but super important to iron out. I literally, I want you to write this down and put it in your cutlery draw for future
负责管理和支付账单，什么时候付，付哪些，这会改变吗？你们将一起买什么，分开买什么？比如杂货，也许你们中的一人有非常昂贵的护发产品。也许你们中的一人有车，另一个人会使用。那么，哪些东西你们会分开付款，哪些会一起付款？如果你们其中一人失去收入或失业，你们的计划是什么？这些都是相当枯燥的问题。超级枯燥，但对于解决问题至关重要。我真的希望你把它写下来，放在你的餐具抽屉里，供将来
reference to come back to. Next, chores and domestic labor. Something seemingly as small as who does the dishes is very symbolically loaded. And the research is full of studies that demonstrate this. The unequal division of household work is. is a significant predictor of relationship breakdown. I think chores are like a microcosm of the relationship. They're super small.
参考并随时回顾。接下来是家务和家务劳动。看似像谁洗碗这样的小事，其实具有非常浓厚的象征意义。相关研究充满了证明这一点的研究。家务劳动的分配不均是关系破裂的一个重要预测指标。我认为家务就像是亲密关系的缩影。它们虽然极小，
Within them, big themes get represented. How do we share responsibility? How do we respect each other's time? How do we express care? And here's the uncomfortable truth about it. You know, in heterosexual relationships in particular, even amongst progressive modern couples, the household load will still tend to fall heavily on women.
但其中却承载着宏大的主题。我们如何分担责任？我们如何尊重彼此的时间？我们如何表达关爱？这里有一个令人感到不舒服的真相。你知道的，特别是在异性恋关系中，即使在开明的现代伴侣中，家务重担往往仍然倾向于落在女性身上。
Multiple studies, including research from the Pew Research Center, from the University of Michigan, they found that women in cohabitating or married relationships still perform a disproportionate share of domestic labor, even when they work more hours at their actual jobs, even when both partners work full time. Sociologists call this, They actually have a name for it.
多项研究，包括皮尤研究中心和密歇根大学的研究都发现，同居或已婚关系中的女性仍然承担着不成比例的家务劳动，即使她们在实际工作中的工作时间更长，即使双方都是全职工作。社会学家称之为——他们实际上给它起了一个名字。
The second shift. It's a term coined by Ali Hotchchild to describe how women often work a full day professionally and they come back and work a second job of managing the household. And it's not always intentional. It's not malicious. It's just deeply ingrained social conditioning. Women are often raised to notice domestic needs. To anticipate when the laundry is piling up, when the bathroom needs scrubbing, when the fridge is empty.
第二班。这是阿里·霍赫希尔德创造的一个词，用来描述女性通常在完成一整天的工作后，回到家还要承担管理家庭的第二份工作。这并不总是有意的。也不是恶意的。这只是根深蒂固的社会习俗。女性从小就被培养去注意家务需求。去预判什么时候衣物堆积如山了，什么时候浴室需要擦洗了，什么时候冰箱空了。
You know, I feel so low. lucky that, and I'm not trying to brag, I know how this is going to come off, but like, my boyfriend does all that stuff. In fact, I think it's unequal for him, which is a win for feminism. But I also know I pay more of the household expenses. So we've just found something that works for us. And I also think that for me, like I take on more of the thinking about our lives. He does more of the physical labor when it comes, or the physical chores when it comes to
你知道，我感到非常幸运，而且我不是在吹牛，我知道这听起来会怎么样，但我男朋友会做所有那些事情。事实上，我认为这对他来说是不公平的，这对女权主义来说是一场胜利。但我也知道我承担了更多家庭开支。所以我们只是找到了一种适合我们的方式。而且我也认为，对我来说，我承担了更多关于我们生活的思考。而当涉及到我们的生活时，他承担了更多体力劳动，或者说体力家务。
our lives. This brings me to the next point. The mental load, the invisible labor of remembering, planning, anticipating. Even in relationships where both partners are trying to be fair when it comes to chores, it's not just about tasks. It's about who keeps track of them. I feel like this is something a lot of men don't realize. Like, women don't want to have to ask you to do something. You doing something because she asked is not as good as you doing something because you anticipated that it needed to be done. So when you move in together, it's really worth having a conversation. What does equal actually mean? What does mental load and the mental energy required for the upkeep of a home actually mean?
这就引出了下一个观点。精神负担，即记忆、规划和预判的隐性劳动。即使在双方都努力在做家务时保持公平的关系中，这也不仅仅关乎具体任务。这关乎谁在追踪这些事情。我觉得这是很多男人没有意识到的一点。比如，女性不希望必须要求你去做某事。你因为她要求才去做某事，并不如你因为预判到需要做而主动去做那么好。所以当你搬到一起住时，真的很值得进行一次对话。平等究竟意味着什么？维护一个家所需的精神负担和精力究竟意味着什么？
Who's going to take that on? How are we going to have conversations around when things may fall off from being equal? because they will, like people get more busy at work, people travel. I just, you need to know who is responsible for those conversations and who is responsible for those activities. The good news, this is one of the easiest things to get right if you're conscious about it. You can very easily create systems that distribute work and mental load that alternate responsibilities if you talk about it openly and if, you know, you're with somebody who is going to be willing to meet you in the middle, meet you halfway. Okay, we're going to take another
谁来承担这些？当事情可能不再处于平等状态时，我们将如何进行对话？因为这种情况会发生，比如人们在工作时会更忙，人们要出差。我只是觉得，你需要知道谁负责这些对话，谁负责这些活动。好消息是，如果你对此有意识，这是最容易做对的事情之一。如果你公开讨论，而且你和一个愿意与你各退一步、各折中一半的人在一起，你可以非常轻松地建立起分工和精神负担、轮流承担责任的体制。好了，我们要再进行一个
quick break, but when we return, let's talk about the two final things you should have ironed out before moving in with somebody and some final tips for keeping the love flowing. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，让我们来谈谈在与某人同居之前应该敲定的最后两件事，以及保持爱意流淌的一些最终建议。所以请留给我们。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为植物油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析事情的经过，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这一关的。包括最近一集邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Then you're finishing that sentence. Yes, I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时准备谈论快克，只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始看出一条贯穿线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆到台面上了，所以。然后你把那句话说完。是的，我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years. for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hardway），我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我自己在心理健康领域的十多年经验，
in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L. Sond's, correct?
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《迎难而上》中就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《迎难而上》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于认领亲子关系丑闻的中心。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。L女士，你对这个特定测试动过两次手脚，对吧？
I doctored the test one. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lepin and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown.
我对测试动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱平和迈克尔·马林奇尼。我的大脑彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻。在马里科帕县，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是这么说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《女朋友们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的是同一个多产的骗子。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我觉得自己像被卡车撞了一下。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So we've talked about mental load. We've talked about money. The next important thing to consider is what happens when you need a loan time. Just because you live together doesn't mean you have to spend every second and every moment together. I think the healthiest thing you can do is maintain a sense of individuality. It's very easy to slip into social dependency, emotional dependency, because your partner is right there.
相信我，宝贝。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听。所以我们讨论了心理负担。我们讨论了金钱。接下来需要考虑的重要事情是，当你需要独处时间时会发生什么。仅仅因为你们住在一起，并不意味着你们必须每分每秒、每时每刻都呆在一起。我认为你能做的最健康的事情就是保持个性感。滑入社会依赖、情感依赖非常容易，因为你的伴侣就在那里。
Independence is what keeps the relationship fresh. I really think it's important before you move in with each other to make sure that your personal lives and your individual lives are just as full and just as fruitful as the life you share together. You have hobbies, you have friends outside of the relationship or you're committed to making new friends outside of the relationship. It's, maybe it's just not something you have to think about, but if you do and if you have any doubts about that, I think give it some time so that you have independent lives before
独立性是保持恋情新鲜感的关键。我真的认为，在你们搬到一起住之前，确保你们的个人生活和独立生活与你们共同的生活一样充实、一样富有成果，这是非常重要的。你有爱好，你在恋爱关系之外有朋友，或者你致力于在恋爱关系之外结交新朋友。这，也许这只是你不需要考虑的事情，但如果你这样做了，如果你对此有任何疑虑，我认为给它一些时间，以便你们在
you merge them. I also think it's really important on the flip side to schedule like dates in with each other, even if you live with each other. You need to have like a little ritual for your relationship. I think couples who keep dating each other tend to have the longest and healthiest relationships because it's no longer passive. They're not just like a roommate. They are somebody that you're actively still falling in love with.
将生活融合在一起之前，拥有独立的生活。我还认为，从另一方面来看，安排彼此约会的日程也非常重要，即使你们住在一起。你们需要为你们的感情建立一个小仪式。我认为那些一直保持约会的情侣往往拥有最长久、最健康的感情，因为这不再是被动的。他们不仅仅像一个室友。他们是你依然在积极地与之坠入爱河的人。
So make sure you schedule the solo dates, schedule the solo nights, also schedule the couple time and the couple dates to make it special. And finally, the final thing you should have ironed out of our five things is what is the protocol on guests? You don't want to feel like you're tiptoeing around your house when your partner's friends are around. You don't want to feel like you have to tell them no when they're. their family visits that, you know, they can't stay in your spare bedroom.
所以，一定要安排好独自约会的日程，安排好独自过夜的日程，还要安排好情侣时间和情侣约会，让它变得特别。最后，我们要理清的五个事项中的最后一项是关于客人的规矩是什么。你可不想在伴侣的朋友在场时，感觉自己在家里蹑手蹑脚的。你也不想在他们的家人来访时，感觉自己不得不对他们说不，你知道的，他们不能住在你的客房里。
Having mismatched comfort levels around these things is normal. It's also going to create tension and it's going to cause you to turn against each other. Have those conversations early. Have them intentionally because when you move in with somebody like you are merging emotional, internal psychological lives. This place is also their place as much as it is yours. And of course, you want them to respect your wishes. but if there is this huge mismatch, it's probably worth just getting to the bottom of before you sign the lease.
对这些事情有不匹配的舒适度是正常的。这也回产生紧张感，并导致你们反目成仇。尽早进行这些对话。刻意地去进行，因为当你和某人同居时，就像是在合并情感、内在的心理生活。这个地方既是他们的，也是你的。当然，你希望他们尊重你的愿望，但如果存在这种巨大的不匹配，在签署租约之前，可能值得彻底弄清楚。
I also think it's a great mark of respect if you're both really considered in these kinds of decisions. It's not the end of the world to change your mind about these things, not the end of the world to have moments where somebody doesn't maybe necessarily think about the other person's feelings as clearly as they should. it's okay to have moments of being really annoyed and frustrating. You are on the same team though. You are partners before you are roommates. Just continue to revise and continue to talk about it. So before we wrap up, I want to give you some final questions to ask yourself before making the biggest, best, greatest decision of moving in with somebody.
我还认为，如果你们在这些决定上都深思熟虑，这也是一种极大的尊重。改变自己对这些事情的想法并不是世界末日，经历某人可能没有像应有的那样清晰地考虑对方感受的时刻也不是世界末日。经历非常恼火和沮丧的时刻是没问题的。不过，你们是在同一个团队。你们首先是伴侣，其次才是室友。只要不断修正并继续讨论即可。因此，在我们结束之前，我想给你一些最后的问题，在做出与某人同居这个最大、最好、最伟大的决定之前，先问问自己。
Answer these in your head. Use them as journal prompts, whatever you need to do. maybe you can even talk about them with your partner, whatever you want. Just have these in the back of your mind. I think they will reveal whether this is the right decision or not. Number one, why do you want to move in? Are you sliding or are you deciding? Is it because it feels right emotionally or convenient financially?
在心里回答这些问题。把它们当作日记提示，无论你需要做什么。也许你甚至可以和你的伴侣讨论它们，随你便。只要把这些放在脑海深处。我认为它们会揭示这是否是正确的决定。第一，你为什么想同居？你是顺其自然（sliding），还是做出了决定（deciding）？是因为情感上感觉对路，还是财务上图个方便？
Neither is necessarily wrong, but just be clear on your intentions. Second, how do you typically individually handle comfort? and is there something that you could be doing or thinking about that could help you handle that better? Third, do you feel emotionally and physically safe with this person? You know, you are going to see each other at your very, very best and your very, very worst. Safety, whether it's emotional, psychological, physical is a non-negotiable? Is this person going to help you grow through hard times and do you feel like you can trust them? Fourth, are you on the same page about the future? not necessarily about marriage, but just about the future in general, what this move means for your
这两者不一定哪个是错的，但要明确你的意图。第二，你通常如何独自处理舒适感？有没有什么事你可以做或思考，能帮你更好地处理它？第三，和这个人在一起，你感到情感上和身体上有安全感吗？你知道的，你们将会看到彼此最好和最糟的一面。安全感，无论是情感的、心理的还是身体的，都是不可妥协的吗？这个人会帮助你在艰难时期成长吗，你觉得你可以信任他们吗？第四，你们对未来的看法一致吗？不一定是关于婚姻，而是关于一般的未来，这次搬家对你们的
relationship. I don't know if anybody else has been watching, nobody wants this, but I feel like there is, I don't want to do spoilers. There is a specific scene in the latest season where they, well, I'm going to spoil it, where they talk about moving in with each other. And I just feel like the way they go about it is quite, well, one of them is quite mature. and like the rabbi is quite mature and Kristen's Bell's character like isn't. But I really agreed with him where he was like, I don't know if we have a future together.
关系意味着什么。我不知道有没有其他人看过《无人同行》，但我感觉有，我不想剧透。在最新一季中有一个特定的场景，他们，好吧，我要剧透了，他们谈论同居。我只是觉得他们处理这件事的方式相当，好吧，其中一个人相当成熟，就像拉比（犹太神职人员）相当成熟，而克里斯汀·贝尔的角色则不然。但我真的很赞同他的观点，他说，我不知道我们是否有未来。
If you have doubts about it, it's not saying you have to know, you don't have to have a ring, but if you can see there is a genuine fundamental incompatibility that you just keep sweeping under the rug, maybe don't do it. Maybe that is a incompatibility that you work through that someone changes their mind about. But just be sure that this is something that's going to, going to be better. and level up your relationship and that the relationship has a future in general. Number five, are you ready to share your space in this way? Love is one thing, living together as another.
如果你对此有疑虑，并不是说你必须全盘了解，你不需要一枚戒指，但如果你能看出存在一种真正的根本性不兼容，而你们却一直把它扫到地毯底下，也许就别同居了。也许那是一种你们可以共同克服的不兼容，或者有人会改变想法。但请务必确保这是一件会让情况变得更好、能将你们的感情提升到新水平的事情，并且这段感情总的来说是有未来的。第五，你准备好以这种方式分享你的空间了吗？恋爱是一回事，同居是另一回事。
You can adore somebody and still realize you're not quite ready to merge your worlds. It's okay to wait. I feel like me and Tom had this discussion where we were like, I'm sure we could do it, but would this give us the best chances of enjoying it? when we like moving in with each other this early on probably not we're not ready to share space we're not ready to share our lives yet in this way we are going to wait and it was a great decision and a bonus question do you feel stable enough in yourself to make this choice now obviously circumstances change maybe you're getting kicked out of your apartment maybe you're super broke
你可以崇拜某人，却依然意识到自己还没有完全准备好融合你们的世界。等待是没问题的。我觉得我和汤姆有过这样的讨论，当时我们在想，我们确信我们能做到，但这会给我们带来享受它的最佳机会吗？当我们在这么早的时候就同居，可能不会，我们还没准备好分享空间，我们还没准备好以这种方式分享生活，我们要等等。这是一个极好的决定。还有一个附加问题：你觉得自己在内心上足够稳定，能现在做出这个选择吗？显然情况会变，也许你被赶出了公寓，也许你超级穷
and you don't feel that stable in your life but ideally you're You should feel like there is not too much chaos going on. There is not too much chaos that is directly impacting this decision. This is a decision I am deciding on rather than sliding into. To give yourself the best chances that this relationship is going to work. You obviously really love this person. You really care about this person. Know yourself.
并且你觉得生活中没有那么稳定，但理想情况下，你应该觉得没有发生太多的混乱。没有太多的混乱直接影响这个决定。这是一个我做出的决定，而不是顺其自然。为了给这段感情带来最好的成功机会。你显然真的很爱这个人。你真的很在乎这个人。了解你自己。
If you have a tendency to rush into things, to self-sabotage, to get really excited. If this person is your forever person, you will get there eventually. you will move in with them eventually. If you feel like your life is not stable enough for you to make a rational choice about it, just hold off, hold off a little bit. I think at its best, like living with your partner in your 20s is really fun and it's really beautiful and you really get to know each other more and it's convenient and it makes financial sense.
如果你有冲动行事、自我破坏、变得异常兴奋的倾向。如果这个人是你的终身伴侣，你最终会走到那一步，你们最终会同居的。如果你觉得自己的生活不够稳定，无法对此做出理智的选择，那就暂缓一下，稍微暂缓一下。我认为在最好的情况下，二十几岁时和伴侣同居真的很有趣，真的很美好，你们真的能更深入地了解彼此，而且很方便，在财务上也说得通。
You do close a chapter of your life that you have to feel ready to close. Like I will say, again, I keep saying this. I love living with Tom. There was definitely a part of me that mourned the fact that unless something really bad happens that I would obviously want to avoid, like one of us dies or we break up. Like, I'm going to be sharing a bed with this man for hopefully the rest of my life. That makes me feel excited. I'm happy about that.
你确实关闭了你生活中的一个篇章，你必须为此做好准备。就像我要说的，我再说一遍。我喜欢和汤姆同居。我内心确实有一部分在哀悼这样一个事实：除非发生非常糟糕且我显然想极力避免的事情，比如我们其中一人死去或者我们分手。我将和这个男人共用一张床，希望直到我的余生。这让我感到兴奋。我对此很高兴。
There is definitely a part of me that did warn, you know, living alone and did mourn the independence of being single and the independence of just being alone in my space and just getting to live and operate every single day without having to think about somebody else. It is like there is obviously like an equation that is inherent in this. You do have to give up something to gain something. Are you ready to give that up? Have you learnt what you needed to learn from your alone time, from your living alone time, from your, even like your single era time, obviously you're not single if like you've been dating
我内心确实有一部分在哀悼，你知道的，独自生活，哀悼单身的独立性，哀悼在自己的空间里独处的独立性，哀悼每天生活和运作时不必考虑其他人的独立性。这显然是一个内在的等式。你必须放弃一些东西才能获得一些东西。你准备好放弃这些了吗？你从独处时间中、从独居时间中、甚至从你的单身时代中（显然如果你和他们约会了一段时间，你就不是单身了）学到了你需要学习的东西吗，
them for a while, but like, I don't know what the word for it is. Alone time. Okay, we'll go with that. With your alone time, you're, okay, I'm going to stop trying to find the right word. Your alone time is what I mean. Just be really, really cognizant of it. You know, you don't want to feel suffocated. You don't want to feel like you rushed into this prematurely and then you have to go back and
但我不知道该怎么称呼它。独处时间。好吧，我们就叫它独处时间吧。好吧，我不打算再去寻找合适的词了。我指的是你的独处时间。只需对此保持非常非常清醒的认识。你知道的，你不想感到窒息。你不想觉得自己操之过急，然后又不得不回去
you have to explain things and, you know, it's going to get messy. I just think the longer you wait, especially the longer you outweigh the honeymoon period, the better it's going to be. So as for the question, should you move in with your partner in your 20s? I don't know. There's no universal answer, but I just think, consider those points, consider those questions, consider the pros and cons. And if you stand to gain more than you stand to lose, which I don't think you will lose
不得不解释事情，你知道的，事情会变得一团糟。我只是认为你等待的时间越长，尤其是你度过热恋期的时间越长，情况就会越好。所以关于这个问题，你在二十几岁的时候应该和伴侣同居吗？我不知道。没有普遍的答案，但我只是觉得，考虑这些点，考虑这些问题，考虑利弊。如果你获得的收益大于付出的代价（我认为你不会失去
all too much, absolutely you should do it. And have the best time at IKEA, have the best time painting. have the best time going house hunting like it's so much fun it's so enjoyable and i'm excited for you and for your next chapter if you made it this far in the episode if you made it all the way to the end leave a little house emoji down below thanks for being a loyal listener thanks for making it to the conclusion of this episode i want to thank our researcher liby colbert for her help on this episode and her contributions if you want to make an episode suggestion if you want to take an episode suggestion if you want to tell me about your experience, moving in with somebody, whether it was good, bad, what your
太多），你绝对应该这么做。祝你在宜家玩的开心，画画玩的开心。去寻找房子玩的开心，这真的很有趣，非常享受，我为你和你的新篇章感到兴奋。如果你听到了这一集的这里，如果你一直听到了最后，请在下方留下一个小房子表情符号。感谢作为一个忠实的听众，感谢你坚持收听这一集的尾声。我要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Liby Colbert）对本集的帮助和贡献。如果你想提出剧集建议，如果你想让我了解你和某人同居的经历，无论是好是坏，你的
tips are, send me a DM on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast and make sure you're following us over there. As well, make sure you are following us wherever you are listening. And please, if you could kindly give us a five-star review, it really helps the show to grow and reach new people, whether you're listening on Apple, on Spotify, on the IHeart Radio app. I would greatly appreciate it. But until next time, thanks again for tuning in. Stay safe. kind, be gentle to yourself. Good luck with the potential move in. And we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four was big to me.
建议是什么，请在 Instagram 上私信我 @That Psychology Podcast，并确保你在那里关注我们无论你在哪里收听，也请确保关注我们。拜托，如果你能慷慨地给我们一个五星好评，无论你是在 Apple、Spotify 还是 iHeart Radio App 上收听，这真的对节目的成长和接触新听众非常有帮助。我将不胜感激。但直到下次，再次感谢您的收听。保持安全。保持善良，对自己温和一点。祝你潜在的搬家一切顺利。我们很快就会在《Look Back at it》播客中再次交流。对 1979 年来说，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。八四年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. I mean, it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important, year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
我是萨姆·J，我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起幸存下来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Marc Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代一样。84 年是个疯狂的年份。我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，各位，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have to be. capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行坦诚的对话，这些对话在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控
of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
生下双胞胎，但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。埃伦斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这里是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness. and building resilience in our strange modern world.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们约会的是同一个多产的骗子时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last. target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。请在 iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts 或您收听播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。